sitting out with hamstring issues but
when you look at this man kyrie irving
one of the best ball handlers in the
game
well tonight this team is going to
continue to do what they've been doing
all year space you out and when you have
ball handlers
it's an easy thing to do but when you
have guys that can set the pick and roll
such as lamarcus aldridge
who's making his next debut tonight it's
going to be fun because he creates space
and by the way he can pick and pop and
knock it down i don't know if i've seen
this many defensive changes
in the first half of a game in my nba
career
they've gone from zone to man to man to
amoeba zone to right now just the
full court press aldrich hits
a three and he's improved in that
department the last couple of years
40 to 16.
the nets 15 for 29 from the field eight
of 15
from three blow out so i could talk
about other things johnson he looks a
little bit like lazy
from the group from the field eight of
15
from three
albridge backing turning and hits
you see the bench let me tell you fans
out there before this game gets carried
away why the bench is so excited
they're excited because aldridge is
doing his moves right there
zella gets a tip in they're not excited
on the three they are but they want to
see that shoulder work they want to see
the guy that they brought over to this
team and what he's going to bring
and i've been a part of take a look post
up by
aldridge working against bridges patton
and move
prior to the game a hug from lamarcus
aldridge to the former assistant coach
of the san antonio spurs jim borrego now
head coach of
of charlotte he played at the university
of san diego he had his coaching career
at his alma mater
and his first pro job was as an
assistant
video coordinator for the spurs that's
right an
assistant video coordinator